Ahsoka Tano and hu Yang travel inside
the mouth of a pergil venturing through
hyperspace to rescue Sabine and stop
thrawn's Sinister plan as the pergols
Embark on their Voyage to a new Galaxy
hyperspace takes on a very different
appearance to what Star Wars fans might
know rather than its usual swirling
white and blue look the simu tunnel the
pergol Pod moves through is streaky and
multicolored featuring green orange and
indigo Hues while this is most likely
how the mines behind Ahsoka wanted to
convey to viewers that the pergils are
traveling to a different galaxy there
could be more to this new hyperspace
look these massive space-faring whales
breathe in a gas called klauson 36 which
their bodies take in and turn into hyper
matter fuel everyone else in the Star
Wars Galaxy can only jump through
hyperspace using a ship with an
operational hyperdrive in this case
their clouds on 36 based fuel is refined
by other means and certainly not inside
the body of a pergal thus You could
argue that the pergil simu tunnel on
Ahsoka looks different than the one
previously seen in Star Wars because
it's Unique to the way in which the
pergil travel